but michael it's funny we showed that
clip uh and we're about to bring in
herman a second because
there it was around that time when a
young knucklehead reporter from the
boston globe
who was covering the nfl uh you know was
dispatched to various locations
throughout the league
and when i tell you hearn edwards not
only put his arm around me
but brought me in his office put me up
on game as we like to say schooled me on
football or life and we had maintained a
relationship ever since i got to call
him colleague at espn for a long time
so it is really a pleasure uh to talk to
you coach and just i'll start off by
saying just thank you for everything
you've meant to me in my career over the
years man it's really good to see you
doing well
well it's good to see you both and thank
you michael uh for your kind words and
when you just mentioned the clip you
know i haven't said
i said the clip one time that was
obviously the day that i said it
but you know residuals come along with
clips
[Laughter]
so my wife is collecting residuals man
that's all i can tell you she's
collecting residuals
you know she's fired up so it's okay
awesome you still got that sense of
humor yo how are you doing
how let's start with the family because
nowadays you got to start with that you
know everything that's going on in our
society and it's the pandemic in
particular
how are you and your family doing well
the families well
uh they're down here with me uh the
girls now
michael are actually 14 and 15. so
they're growing up one's in high school
and one's about to go to high school
next year and uh
they've adjusted obviously we still have
our place in california but uh we're
here at residence now and um
it's been a lot of fun to watch them
grow up around the football team
all of a sudden they've inherited 110
big brothers right
so that's a good thing they go to all
the games and all that stuff and i don't
know about this year obviously
with what's going on but uh it's been
fun to watch them grow up
around the football team especially
know you know what uh coach you know
michael said you guys are colleagues
at espn and i just got so used to you
doing your thing at espn
i said no no no no he he has coached
he's coached in the nfl he's not going
back to coach he's not going back to
college football
what did it what got you back there uh
at arizona state
well the relationship obviously with ray
anderson or a.d
and our president dr crow and
you know sitting at espn i think it was
a marvelous uh a platform for me and i i
can't say enough about how they treated
me there
um but but i got the itch a little bit
coaching the under armour all-american
game for all those years
and then this opportunity came about and
it was an opportunity not only to be the
football coach but
really to to complete young men to grow
young men up
and i missed it i missed the camaraderie
of the coaches
of the players of of getting in the
huddle and competing
and it was just the right place if not
for here
i'd probably still be working on a
worldwide leader
but it's worked out pretty well thus far
we're trying to build a program a lot of
work involved in it
got a great coaching staff and we're
starting to get some talented players
and you know you're only as good as your
players now the one thing i figured out
in the nfl when you have a quarterback
you're a pretty good coach so
we have a quarterback so i got a chance
you know you took the words right out of
my mouth on two fronts starting with the
staff that you've assembled you got
antonio pierce
marvin lewis kevin mawei derek hagan you
got an all-star coaching staff but i
want to go back to completing
and growing young men because coach even
before you know you were coming on today
i've been having conversations with
people
close to you in your program dr herb
martin i talked to
as well as your deputy athletic director
gene boyd
just about what you guys are doing off
the field within this program
uh is it scholar ballers did i did i get
that right
yeah we have all that yeah yeah tell
people about what you guys are doing
this this unique set of circumstances uh
with the staff you have but the support
system you have in place when it comes
to setting these young men up not just
for the next level of
football but the next level of life well
it really is it is life
the life skills you teach through
football is really uh resonating here uh
when you think about
the guys that come here um you know
they're gonna graduate we're gonna make
sure they do that but but i think
all the things that happen in life when
you're a college athlete
um you have a form and you have a
platform to speak on it
uh you know when we talked about the
protests i mean first thing we did is we
called our players in
and i mentioned to them i said you know
you have a voice in this because you
have a platform but you have to be the
voice of reason
and you have to have solutions when you
speak right
uh we have registered all our players to
vote uh that was important to us the
pac-12
has done a nice job of really carving
out a day in november where
we're not even going to practice uh
we're gonna we're gonna go vote
we had our players registered to vote i
think that was important you know all
these things that
you have to understand as a young man
growing up
um they're part of the program and i
think when we can
ingrain this in these young men because
we feel this way they leave here
and someone will have enough talent to
go to pro football
but most of them will go on with their
life's work whatever they may be but
they leave here hopefully better men for
it
and we've raised them up not only as
football players uh but but but
soon to be fathers husbands right
whatever they do in the working world i
mean
we're going to try to grow them up right
here in this program so we allow them to
have some success when they leave
i love that coach i love that mentality
and i love that that whole perspective
you know two of those guys who are in
the pros you've coached
uh two wide receivers uh first rounders
the last couple of years
uh they're gonna be meeting on sunday uh
49ers and patriots brandon ayuk and uh
nikhil harry
now i know brandon had a touchdown last
night nikhil harry
went without a reception and he's
getting a little criticism
uh in new england people are wondering
hey is this guy really is he a boss is
he not a good player
what do you think is going on with him
is he in the wrong office
uh you know what's going on to kill
harry from what you can see
well first of all captain america is no
longer there right and and so
football player now i'm a cam fan as
well um
but with that being said the offense all
of a sudden has changed
dramatically with cam playing
quarterback and nikhil and i think you
know it's like anything else
a quarterback and receiver working
together
um that helps as well and so i just
think you know
it's going into a second second season
he's a strong will guy
very talented player um you know
sometimes
you know you got to grow up and it's
hard and it's not every year is not
going to be a great season
and not saying he can't have a great
season this year but he's still young
and i think it takes time
especially in that offense you know
there's a lot to do with that offense
and
and i just think as he continues to play
this season um
you're going to hear from him uh he's a
he's a good football player now
and not just that offense but this all
season or even really just this last
week or so i mean belichick talked
yesterday about it they can't practice
so right pivoting to your program coach
you guys november 7th y'all starting at
usc
um can you can you describe for us
like the readiness of your team right
now your preparation
how do you prepare for something uh you
know have a structured routine where you
know
this is unprecedented coach so where is
your team right now in terms of its
preparation
well i i think we got what two and a
half weeks left
um but but emotionally um we're excited
about playing i mean you can
anticipate that but but now it's more of
um being in shape to play and i think
any team that started out this season
whether it was the nfl or college teams
that already started before we have
the first thing you realize is those
first couple games
no one really is in football shape per
se because you haven't played right
and so that's going to be the big deal i
think when we start our season off now
there's only six games
and every game is in our conference
which is very you know which is a tough
conference we beat each other up and
and we've we've got a very very good
team that we're playing against i mean
one of the most talented teams in our
conference is usc
and they have a bonded offense uh they
have a lot of
good players on defense as well so you
know we've played them twice since i've
been here
and the total score of both those games
win or lose has been eight points
so both games have gone down to the
fourth quarter and who can hold on so uh
this is going to be quite a game for us
you know jane daniels our quarterback
did not play against usc last year he
was injured so he's going back home he's
going to go in the coliseum
sad thing about it not many folks will
be in the coliseum except the players
so that's going to be interesting yeah
right
hey all right coach i had a couple uh
quick uh questions for you now
i i am not really into trivia
asking people trivia questions but i
think you might be able to handle this
one
okay the new york jets new york jets
right now or 016 and
uh the organization is struggling a bit
i'm just wondering
if you could think of the last head
coach of the new york jets to win the
afc east i'm just
i'm just wondering if you know who that
guy is yeah i i i kind of know how that
how that works right
and um well we you know it's kind of
interesting you say that because uh
we started out bad we were two and five
believe it or not and we ended up
winning the division
and that was the whole what you just why
you introduced me
that was that speech right that was that
speech
and we ended up winning the division got
on a run and had a really good football
team had a good quarterback and
chad pennington and had a veteran team
and kevin mcguire was a part of it
curtis smart was our running back we had
a really good defense as well
and uh played good i mean i i really
enjoyed my time in new york to be quite
honest um
uh but then again i got you know i got
traded to kansas city but then
things kind of just happened but uh i
really enjoyed
youtube coaches can say that for new
york very fast right
coach you can say that michael holland
that they got treated
for a driver
it is what it is you know
but you know i'm wondering coach when
you look at the jets
um yeah and look hey i don't know if
they still owe you money they probably
don't owe you money anymore so just yeah
just tell us
everything no no no if you had to
advise somebody like a young coach let's
say michael smith wants to get into
coaching he's gonna be the head coach of
the new york jets
what what would you say what's the
advice coaching in new york is different
coaching with the jets is different
what's the advice for success in that
situation
well i think the one thing you have to
do is
the players you have to earn the players
trust
at any level of coaching and that comes
with being consistent
and when they're in a situation like
they are now and they've got some
veteran coaches on that staff
um you got to provide players with hope
they have to have hope i mean that that
that energizes everybody and i've been
in those situations trust me
where it's tough man i mean we you know
we went through that uh when i was with
kansas city after my first year getting
into playoffs and the next two years was
weren't very good we didn't have a
quarterback obviously a lot of things we
were trying to build a team with young
players
um but they're close i mean they're
still competing at the game last
uh last night i believe it was yesterday
i watched um
it got away from them in the first
quarter in the first half but
uh they came back and they had a chance
and so
that says something about how they're
playing now and now people in new york
will say well they've quit
they haven't quit uh professionals don't
quit what they lose they lose energy
and they lose hope you know energy is a
powerful word now
and then hope hope gives them energy how
can you provide them hope
and i think if they could just get off
to a good start
you know and and lead a game for a
little while because
that would give them some hope there's a
lot of football left
and um you know they're professionals
and they know this that when they walk
on that field
regardless of what the score is or how
many games you want or lost
that's your resume you know you write
your resume
every time you put it on tape as a
professional football player you have an
obligation
you have an obligation to be a
professional football player
and to play up to your ability because
remember
you are actually performing for 30 what
31 other teams
that's how it works yep yep i remember
that was one year coach
um would you go through four
quarterbacks in new york one year oh
yeah um
five five five five there you go i mean
you've you've you've seen it all i mean
you coached yes
um you know in new york uh during 9 11
um you know you've uh you you've been
you've seen it all and got to been there
done that got the t-shirt as they say
yeah but this challenge right now in
this pandemic
uh when it comes to social distancing
and testing and
covid and opt-outs and and even just you
know the ups and downs
even if y'all would have a season in the
pac-12 coupled with the political
climate that we're in you mentioned all
your players are registered to vote
how would you compare this current
challenge that you're experiencing at
asu with everything else you've seen and
experienced
in your football career well
nothing comes close to this and you're
right i was involved in the 911
situation
and that was that was catastrophic
there's no doubt about that
about that but this situation is
entirely different
yes it's it's uh you know every day
you know that you go to practice uh
i always tell players this look we're
fighting two things every day we go to
work
uh we're fighting to stay healthy in
practice and we're fighting the virus
that we can't see and then once the
season starts you actually compete
against
the competition and you have you you
have two people you're trying to
defeat right the opponents you play on
the field and the opponent
uh you play off the field that you can't
see
yeah yeah you know coach you mentioned
uh
some of the opponents i'm just thinking
about this as a college football coach
and you tell me this is going to change
we know like some of our norms
are just are not coming back some of
them aren't i'm not trying to say it's
going to be awful it's just going to be
a different
way of doing business and for a college
football coach
how does one recruit during a pandemic
how does that change are you are you
strictly zoom are you zooming with these
guys now like
zoom zoom zoom zoom zoom zoom is our way
right it's a way of coming right now
it's unbelievable it really is um
and it says a lot about our coaching
staff and the ability to do
you know and michael knows i i didn't
own a cell phone until i went to espn i
didn't elect trump i'm about to say
man right and so
it's just one of those deals you have to
adjust um but i think
you know this is this is america and uh
we will find our way through this
and the world will find its way through
this as well you know and
when you think about what we're in right
now um you you cannot
uh the first responders enough
for their sacrifices and and what they
have done for the what
what is it now going almost nine months
yeah um
can you imagine their life uh you know
they're dealing with this
at you know they're dealing with up
close and personal
and to put their lives in harm's way
every day they go to work
knowing that they're serving their
communities and trying to help people
that obviously catch the virus
says a lot about them and who they are
and they can't be thanked enough
i mean they cannot be thanked enough and
i pray for them every night
before i lay down you know because this
is something guys that
we we haven't hopefully we'll never see
this again
this has been tough and i think when it
started no one anticipated
november guys and we're still in this
it's november this started out in march
man
we may be going through it for a while
so with that i want to coach like
typically like you focus on your own
house and your own team and what you can
control
instead of the other but watching what
other conferences are dealing with
specifically the scc
i mean you know you got coaches testing
positive you know uh cancellations
postponements
any takeaways or anything you can learn
from watching other conferences
go before the pac-12 or it's just every
day has its own thing and you you take
it as a country
you know i mean every conference is
trying to protect um all those involved
coaches and players um you have to do
that
and i think that that is what we talk
about all the time
um and there's like i said you're you're
the the opponent is invisible
and as much protocol as you take all it
takes is one person being in the wrong
place at the right time
um it could affect your football team it
could affect your organization we've
seen it in every sport
and i think that was that was understood
going in
um that this thing is it could get to
you and when it does
uh the procedures you're going to have
to take to make sure you alleviate it as
fast as you can
but i take my hat off to all the the
coaches and the players
for all the sports that have uh that
have contacted the virus
and what they have done to try to
eliminate it
and it's very difficult guys it just is
it's no one's fault you know people
think sometimes it's your fault
i don't know if it's anyone's fault it's
just
we live in a world that's socially we
like to socialize
and i think the first two months of this
we were all we're all
aware hey we're going to go inside and
all that but then we got tired
we got tired and we thought it went away
it's still here guys it's not going away
hey coach we can't thank you enough for
your time before i let you go um
please give my regards to your whole
staff but antonio ray antonio
and marvin in particular just real quick
last thing
um what are what are y'all meetings like
what does it mean with you and marvin
lewis and
your peers i mean i just want to be a
flyer on the wall for your staff
meetings
you got to come in when this thing's
over you got to come out and visit both
you guys come out and visit us do the
show out here man
and come visit us and you can sit in the
meetings and you can see i tell you what
a lot of fun now a lot of knowledge
a lot a lot a lot of dollars walking
around in the building
oh i imagine it's a privilege to play
for y'all hey coach always a privilege
to talk to you thank you so much
god bless you and your family on the
program and uh
you guys are doing great man appreciate
what you do thank you coach